Andreas Wickberg loves
taking the snowmobile
to his house in the
icy reaches of Lapland.
All four houses in his tiny
Arctic community
rely on satellite internet
for 500 kroner a
month, about $50.
Wickberg and his wife
can hole up at home
with a satellite internet
connection fast enough to do
work calls by day and
stream movies by night.
On the morning of
February 24, 2022,
he turned on his computer
and gulped down the news that
Russian President Vladimir Putin
had begun an invasion of Ukraine.
A little while later,
his neighbor came around
asking to borrow his Wi-Fi code
saying their internet
connection had dropped.
Wickberg shared the code
and kept going at work.
10 minutes later his
connection dropped, too.
He checked. All four
modem lights were off.
That meant it was no
longer communicating with
a hulking great
geostationary satellite
that beams down 82 individual spots
across Europe and Northern Africa,
more than 20,000 miles
above him in the sky.
It turned out his was one tiny
part of the biggest public outage
of satellite internet
ever recorded.
More than 45,000
modems had to be replaced,
yet it would take 35 days for the
global communications
company affected,
Viasat, to even begin to say what
it thought had happened,
and 75 days for any country
to point the finger officially.
Back on Earth, Wickberg knew instantly what had happened.
It had to be Russia.
A few hours earlier and
several time zones away
on an overcast evening
in Austin, Texas,
a senior Viasat official settled
in at home for the night.
Automated alerts
suddenly started pinging
indicating abnormal
activity in Ukraine.
Modems across much of Europe
were unable to make
an internet connection.
Viasat workers tried to force
offline modems that seemed
overwhelmed by malicious traffic,
but more kept coming.
They were playing satellite
modem Whac-A-Mole.
The real target was more
than a 1,000 miles
and half a continent away from
Andreas Wickberg’s Lapland hideaway.
Satellite communications
that Ukraine's government,
army and intelligence
rely on were down.
This catastrophic communications
loss hampered their defenses.
Backup came later in the form of
Elon Musk's Starlink terminals.
These were game changing,
but they left the country reliant
on support from an
erratic billionaire.
The debilitating Ukraine hack
was also a wake-up call
to the commercial satellite industry.
Almost all of daily life
turns on satellites, even time.
Commercial satellites
determine GPS coordinates
that underpin digital clocks
and cash machines.
Space is playing an
even bigger role in
homes, transport, food supply,
military operations,
banking and communications.
The risks are only set to rise.
Today, there are close to 5,000
active satellites on orbit.
In the next ten years that
number could hit 100,000.
While Andreas Wickberg
waited on one of the 45,000+
replacement modems
Viasat was busy sending out,
he decided to mail a
faulty one to an expert.
A week later, Ruben Santamarta
opened the package, thrilled.
A leading light in a very
small global band
of cybersecurity researchers who
are obsessed with satellite systems.
Santamarta immediately
pulled the modem apart
and dumped what's called
the flash memory.
That's the part of the device that stores key rewritable data.
In place of a series of words,
strings and numbers
common to code and
working modems,
he found orderly repetition.
Far from a temporary glitch,
the destructive pattern
indicated a malware attack.
Viasat admitted the
attack was preventable,
but said they hadn't had
the capability to stop it.
An attacker, they said, had
In other words, they got
hacked pretty bad.
It took four weeks for the
US intelligence community
to conclude Russia's
military intelligence unit,
the GRU, carried out the attack.
The US then embarked on a six
week quiet diplomatic campaign
to publicly blame it on Russia.
An unusual step that made
some European countries,
including France and Germany,
nervous in case it made things worse.
But the argument went that
this was the most important
cyber attack of the
Russian invasion.
One no one who
subscribed to the service
could do anything to stop.
And one that could happen again.
Eventually, the European
Union went public
with the US careful to go second,
an effort to send a signal to
Russia that everyone was united.
The final frontier is still vastly
underprepared for cyber attacks.
Commercial satellite
companies are still too lax
when it comes to security
and some government satellite systems were built 30, 40 years ago,
making them
especially vulnerable.
Starlink's Ukraine service has already faced attacks of their own
and Viasat says it faces
ongoing threats.
Russia has publicly warned
since the invasion
it sees some commercial satellites
as legitimate targets for retaliation.
The US intelligence
community says
Moscow will seek weapons that
can identify, track and target
US satellites at speed
during a conflict.
And the attack, say experts,
is super, super repeatable.